impfen impfen und testen testen testen
sind die fakten fakten fakten so
einleuchtend so schwierig denn die
lieferketten für die wichtigsten waffen
gegen korona sind störanfällig und die
politik hechelt mit ankündigungen und
schnappatmung hinterher auch weil die
wichtige wahlen ins haus stehen kann man
es besser machen ja glauben zu
mindestens einige schlaumeier in unserer
nachbarschaft hehre ziele harte realität
wie kommen wir an tests und impfstoffe
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio cerstin gammelin
ist bei uns stellvertretende leiterin
des parlamentsbüros der süddeutschen
zeitung hier in berlin ebenfalls in
berlin stationiert wenn die linie von
britta die korrespondentin von ökonom
ist der bekannten und legendären
londoner wirtschaftszeitung zugeschaltet
aus den haag
thomas kutschker der korrespondent der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung
eigentlich ist ihr dienstsitz brüssel
dort zuständig für eu nato und eben auch
die beneluxstaaten und im moment in den
niederlanden unterwegs und mein kollege
wolf christian ulrich der korrespondent
des zdf in wien
cerstin gammelin gestern im kanzleramt
neun stunden haben da die köpfe geraucht
was dann als ergebnis herauskam kann man
da sagen dass der zeitliche aufwand und
der inhaltliche ertrag in einem
vernünftigen verhältnis zueinander
standen
na ja das kommt drauf an nase wenn sie
sehen dass man das alles dann eine
schöne grafik pressen kann was man da
beschlossen hat dann muss ich schon
sagen dann hat sie sich lohnt
andererseits wenn man sich das
inhaltlich im ganz ganz genau anschaut
kommt man nicht zu diesem schluss also
es lässt sich vielleicht am besten
zusammenfassen der bürger hat öffnungen
bestellt und der bürger hat jetzt auch
lockerungen bekommen
ob es funktioniert hängt natürlich jetzt
wirklich sehr davon ab ob diese ganzen
kleinteilig zivilisierten regelungen
überhaupt verstanden und eingehalten
werden und ob die leute auch lust haben
sich darauf einzulassen also ich glaube
es hängt jetzt einfach sehr viel daran
dass die leute damit ziehen die
eu-kommission hat man das gefühl sitzt
auf der anklagebank politischem versagen
lautet die beschuldigung gerichtet ist
das besonders gegen die präsidentin
ursula von der leyen ist diese
alleinschuld these zu halten
nein allein ist sie natürlich nicht
schuld
man muss auch ganz klar sagen
das was die eu da gemacht hat ist
natürlich ohne eine präsidentin so
kurzer zeit auf eine pandemie zu
reagieren das ist ja zunächst mal auch
etwas was man positiv festhalten muss
dass alle staaten sich entschlossen
haben hier über die kommission zu gehen
wo die kommission eigentlich in der
gesundheitspolitik ja keine besonderen
kompetenzen hat so und dann hat man sich
in diese an dieses abenteuer gemacht
manche sachen haben gut funktioniert das
muss man sagen insbesondere was die
entwicklung des impfstoffs angeht klar
da hat die kommission natürlich keine
unmittelbare rolle gespielt sie hat sich
aber schon die richtigen hersteller
rausgesucht sie hat auch viel schneller
als es übliches impfstoffe zugelassen
aber sie hat zu wenig bestellt und sie
hat viel zu spät gemerkt dass das
eigentliche problem nicht die
entwicklung sondern die industrielle
produktion ist und jetzt muss man
hinterher hecheln hat natürlich sehr
große erwartungshaltungen geschaffen
und da sehe ich eigentlich das
hauptproblem von frau von der leyen als
kommissionspräsidentin sie hat eben
diese erwartungen geschürt sie ist eine
frau die gerne mit großen überschriften
und ankündigungen arbeitet ja und dann
plötzlich anfang januar standen wir alle
da und haben gesehen
es kommt gar nichts an die situation im
vereinigten königreich ist da ganz
anders da wird ja gerade das fleming
also das argumentationsmuster das land
stünde beim impfen des nur deswegen so
gut da weil es gerade noch rechtzeitig
die eu verlassen hat haben die briten
also von der pandemie nichts mehr zu
befürchten
doch natürlich also erstens gibt es die
britische mutation die britische
variante und die die ist ja besonders
ansteckend also es ist ist in den
intensivstationen in großbritannien
immer noch hochbetrieb und state of
emergency es immer noch ausnahmezustand
also ist nicht so dass sich die lage da
völlig entspannt hat aber die briten
haben eine sache ganz anders gemacht und
würde ich auch sagen das haben sie mal
besser gemacht haben sehr viele fehler
in der ganzen kroner krise gemacht das
haben sich wirklich gut gemacht sie
haben eine frau die ist die würde die
hat das auf freiwilliger basis gemacht
kate bringe heißt sie ist mit einem tor
im minister verheiratet und sie ist
eigentlich ein kommt aus dem
investmentbanking und die hat das wie so
eine business projekt gemacht und hat
einfach gekauft was sie bekommen konnte
egal was es gekostet hat und hat das
eben sehr schnell sehr effizient und
sehr viel impfstoff eingekauft und
dadurch dass es ein zentralisiertes
gesundheitssystem gibt konnte natürlich
auch sehr schnell und sehr effizient
info mit dem resultat dass jetzt 30
prozent der briten geimpft sind
das ist schon also wenn man das mit
deutschland ich glaube jetzt 5 prozent
und roth sein vergleicht ist das schon
beachtlich und deshalb ist natürlich die
angst vor der mutanten oder vor der
britischen mutation nicht ganz nicht
mehr ganz so schlimm weil eben doch
jetzt schon relativ viel und sie kämpfen
und auch noch in den nächsten das ist ja
ein exportartikel ganz für den kontinent
gewesen weil da hat man nämlich angst
vor der politischen mut an der b 11 7
wolltest du dich ein schlaumeier ist ja
mutmaßlich ist ja entschuldigung dass
sebastian kurz der bundeskanzler
der österreichische bundeskanzler der
heute in israel ein im bündnis
geschmiedet hat israel dänemark und eben
österreich und zwar weil er
offensichtlich mit der eu impfkampagne
sehr unzufrieden ist ist das der einzige
grund oder steckt da auch noch etwas
anderes dahinter
na ja also ich weiß nicht aber ein
schlaumeier ist er ist wie viele hier in
der gegend natürlich unzufrieden mit der
art und weise wie die impfkampagne für
die eu organisiert worden ist in
deutschland ist man nicht zufrieden
damit in österreich ist man nicht dazu
nicht damit zufrieden und in den
nachbarländern auch nicht das ziel
dieser reise ist jetzt ja kein ad hoc
ziel sondern das hat schon zu beginn der
pandemie und auch im sommer versuche
gegeben von israel zu schauen kriegt man
nicht partner für eine zusammenarbeit
kurz hat damals wohl noch gesagt nein
wir organisieren dieser impfstoff mit
der eu gemeinsam
jetzt möchte er natürlich seinen image
waren als der manager der korona manager
der nach vorne denkt und das heft des
handelns
die hand nimmt auch für zukünftige
mutanten und varianten die uns mit
corona noch ärgern werden
man darf aber nicht vergessen der
schlaumeier wenn sie so wollen ist nicht
nur kurz sondern sitzt hier auch in der
anderen benachbarten hauptstädten die
ihre augen auch von brüssel weg lenken
und die hilfe woanders suchen zb hier in
den östlichen nachbarländern die nach
moskau schauen nach peking schauen die
sich fragen warum nehmen wir jetzt nicht
sputnik und sinopharm wenn es irgendwie
machbar ist die not zulassungen
organisieren und die gefahr damit ist
nicht nur dass man nachher eine
gemeinsame eu im politik damit in frage
gestellt sondern da können wir
vielleicht auch später noch mal drauf
kommen
das ist natürlich auch in fremden
effekte hat auch die eu da werden viele
leute auch gerade enttäuscht in ihren
erwartungen an eine richtig gut
organisierte eu und da steckt meiner
ansicht nach doch eine große gefahr
wären diese länder meinte ich auch
vorher mit meine bemerkung zu den
schlaumeiern in unserer nachbarschaft
kommen darauf auf jeden fall noch zu
sprechen
kennen sie den neben corona grassiert in
deutschland ein weiteres wir uns nämlich
das virus die ungeduld und zwar sowohl
bei den bürgerinnen bürgern wie auch bei
der wirtschaft erst die quittungen
könnten da am 14 märz bei den
landtagswahlen ausgestellt werden
wie ist denn unter diesen umständen das
ist ja nicht nur ein eindruck den auch
schon druck den griff und wahlen ausgeht
wie ist denn da das krisen-management zu
bewerten
also wir haben im moment ja eine sehr
sagen wir mal eine sehr explosive
mischung aus landtagswahlen aus dem
virus und aus diesen lockerungen ja und
wir haben jetzt schon mal gesehen dass
die landtagswahlen jetzt in rheinland
pfalz und baden baden württemberg wird
in dem ich stattfinden dass der
wahlkampf schon ganz andere ist dass man
den online führen muss und dass
natürlich diese länder jetzt auch darauf
gedrängt haben zu lockern also
baden-württemberg zum beispiel mit den
schulen ist wollte die cdu kandidatin
und bin unbedingt lockern
auch malu dreyer wollte lockerungen
haben und man hat es gestern abend im
kanzleramt natürlich auch gemerkt dass
dieser wahlkampf über den
über den verhandlungen sozusagen
geschwebt hat und so kann man sich
eigentlich auch nur erklären dass
eigentlich wider besseres wissen
lockerung beschlossen wurden sind die
sich dann wiederum zur begründung auf
dinge stützen die in deutschland nicht
funktionieren bisher jedenfalls nicht
dass impfungen das testen also wenn man
das sich mal so ansieht ist das schon
sehr überraschender kurswechsel der
gestern beschlossen worden ist und der
ist beschlossen wurden wegen der wahl
scheint ihren die politische klasse in
deutschland auch verunsichert im moment
ja natürlich ich glaube jeder ist
verunsichert weil einerseits wenn man
zum beispiel nach tschechien oder in die
slowakei schaut ist da wirklich
alarmstufe eins nicht die kommen das
gesundheitssystem bricht da wirklich
fast zusammen und andererseits möchte
die bevölkerung wirklich locker und und
und es ist auch nicht mehr die
bereitschaft so viele opfer zu bringen
und was alles in einem superwahljahr
nicht also man muss einerseits ist die
gefahr noch da die ist bei weitem noch
nicht ausgestanden andererseits hat die
bevölkerung zieht nicht mehr mit also
wie macht man das ich wäre auch für
unsere völker und zweimal ich finde
immer man muss ein bisschen
differenzierter debattieren weil man
kann nicht sagen die bevölkerung zieht
nicht mehr mithalten die versuchung ist
zur hälfte immer noch dafür dass strenge
regeln gelten es sind einfach die die
lockern wollen sehr sehr laute dass man
annimmt die wollen alle raus ist aber
auch objektive umfragen nämlich ob die
bevölkerung mitzieht und wer da nicht
mehr mitzieht oder wie viele noch
mitziehen und ich schauen wir uns mal
eine umfrage an aus dem deutschlandtrend
da geht es nämlich um die frage
zufriedenheit mit der bundesregierung
seit januar 2020 das der beginn der
pandemie ab märz des letzten jahres ein
steiler anstieg über 60 prozent also
etwa zwei drittel sehr zufrieden
ja und ab januar geht es dann bergab
also so etwa um den jahreswechsel
scheint da die stimmung zu kippen
geht nicht gibt es nicht heißt man sagt
man ja so schön die regierungen die
bundesregierung aber auch die anderen
regierungen wollen hier immer möglichst
ein kontrollverlust vermeiden
es werden ankündigungen gemacht man hat
das heft in der hand muss aber dann auch
rückzieher machen ist das eine krux im
moment
für die für die politiker ich denke es
ist eine sehr große crux wir haben ja
gestern abend auch sehr viel rückzieher
gesehen also zum beispiel die test
strategie von spahn ist korrigiert
wurden die inzidenz zahl 35
die aso der dreh und angelpunkt für
lockerungen sein sollte es kassiert
wurden durch die 50 ersetzt wurden wir
haben eine inzidenz zahl von 100 die
noch nirgendwo da gewesen ist man kann
jetzt auch den impfstoff anders für
impfen also da ist sehr viel bewegung in
der beschlusslage und begründung lage
und das verunsichert natürlich
zusätzlich gut
trotzdem hat sich der
bundesgesundheitsminister ist heute
nicht nehmen lassen im bundestag trotz
seiner schlechten erfahrungen in den
letzten wochen gemacht hat noch mal zu
sagen was in den nächsten wochen zu
erwarten ist jens spahn heute im
bundestag wir schauen jetzt kurz den
ausschnitt an
april werden die arztpraxen routinemäßig
mit impfen
jeden tag zigtausende hunderttausende
später millionen wir müssen schneller
werden weil der impfstoff am anfang
knapp kommt er jetzt in steigenden menge
ja herr gottschalk was da an gekündigt
worden ist also es wird alles besser ab
april gibt es richtig viel impfstoffe
deckt sich das mit dem was sie
einschätzen dass das im management der
eu angeht was da verhandelt worden ist
was da jetzt nachverhandelt wurde was
noch vision danach bestellt wurde kann
jens spahn bei dieser äußerung bleiben
oder muss er da wieder einen rückzieher
machen also hier wird genauso
argumentiert im zweiten quartal wird
alles besser
natürlich noch nicht so viele impfstoffe
wird es geben um alle zu impfen
aber die kommission hat ja das ziel
ausgegeben dass 70 prozent der
erwachsenen europäischen bevölkerung das
sind ungefähr 255 millionen europäer bis
zum sommer geimpft sind und zwar
komplett also wenn erforderlich mit
jeweils zwei dosen und sie sagt man bis
zum sommer das ist natürlich den bau der
sommer endet
ende september und vermutlich wird es in
vielen ländern auch so lange dauern
aber im moment ist es so dass die
kommission nach ihren eigenen
projektionen sagt diese stil ist
geschaffen man muss ja immer sagen
insgesamt sind mittlerweile 2,6
milliarden dosen bestellt das reicht
natürlich wenn es alles geliefert wurde
um jeden europäer fünf mal und öfter zu
impfen
natürlich ist nur ein teil dieser menge
wirklich garantiert und die große
unbekannte ist eben und das bleibt auch
so in den nächsten wochen ob die
hersteller ihre verpflichtungen
einhalten können die eu-kommission hat
ja auch den druck erhöht indem sie ein
export kontrollsystem eingeführt hat
dass sie anfang der woche auch zum
ersten mal eingesetzt hat um eine
lieferung von astrazeneca die von
italien in italien abgefüllt worden ist
und nach australien gehen sollte
untersagt hat weil dieses unternehmen
geben zuerst seine vertraglichen
verpflichtungen in europa erfüllen muss
da sieht man noch sind wir nicht in
einer komfortablen lage noch wird hier
geht es hier wirklich dosis und dosis
herr ullrich ist das denn in österreich
und auch in den umliegenden ländern die
sich schon genannt haben wie tschechien
slowakei und ungarn ist da dass
vertrauen einfach zu gering geworden
dass genügend impfstoff bekommen und
jetzt denkt man sich eben mit russischen
und chinesischen impfstoff also in
ungarn in der slowakei ein und der
österreichische bundeskanzler macht eine
reise nach jerusalem um möglicherweise
fehlbestände auszugleichen fehle das
vertrauen in die europäische union in
die fähigkeiten der eu also außerhalb
von österreich würde ich sagen das ist
vertrauen
fehlt das ist klar in österreich selbst
glaube ich ist das ein bisschen anders
natürlich ist man hier unzufrieden
natürlich sehen die leute auch es gibt
einen impfstoff wir wollen ihnen haben
er kommt zu langsam
also was tun wir jetzt man muss auch
sagen dass in österreich die situation
im vergleich zu deutschland ein bisschen
anders ist weil es hier eine sehr gute
test strategie gibt die doch das
öffentliche leben ein bisschen
erleichtert aber was sie angesprochen
haben auch vorher alles hängt an der
impfung die normale weg zurück in die
normalität hängt an der impfung
ich habe jetzt gerade in der zeitung
gelesen dass es in österreich
unternehmer gibt die nicht mehr warten
möchten die wissen das in konkurrenz
betrieben in anderen ländern
außenhandels mitarbeiter geimpft sind
wie sich jetzt versuchen also auf dem
balkan oder in israel restposten zu
organisieren
mit kühl flugzeugen um die eigenen
mitarbeiter zu impfen weil sie sagen
unser staat gericht ist nicht so schnell
hin
wir brauchen die österreichische im
strategie hat hier vorgesehen dass man
jetzt im moment mit märz schon mit denen
mit den kritischen infrastrukturen
anfängt mit der impfung da sind wir
lange nicht und alles nicht eben daran
dass der impfstoff nicht so schnell
kommt wie er soll
er fühlt sich aber meiner ansicht nach
die österreichische regierung doch noch
mehr an die vorgaben oder sozusagen an
den brüsseler gemeinsamen akkord
gebunden als es dann regierungen doch im
osten tun also dass viktor orban hingeht
und sagt mir reicht ist alles nicht
brüssel arbeitet mir nicht schnell genug
passt natürlich andererseits perfekt in
sein politisches konzept vor uns sowieso
der schuldige für viele fehler ist aber
er hat daneben beziehungen spielen
lassen ein russischen hat jetzt auch
chinesischen stimmt impfstoff besorgt
hat sich auch selbst
öffentlichkeitswirksam mit chinesischen
impfstoff impfen lassen weil er gemerkt
hat dass eine bevölkerung von der
wirksamkeit nicht ganz so überzeugt ist
in der slowakei gibt es die regel zum
bestellungen für zwei millionen sputnik
dosen tschechien möchte mit china und
mit russland verhandeln in kroatien ist
es seit zwei drei wochen so ein hin und
her sollte man gesagt ja wir hätten
gerne den sputnik aber natürlich nur
wenn die gema die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde
damit zieht jede grüne
gesundheitsminister anschober hat vor
ein paar tagen gesagt ja natürlich ist
sputnik vorsteher aber natürlich die ema
und kann nicht bitte russland jetzt
endlich die anträge einreichen was man
sieht ist es kommt zu wenig an und man
muss ja auch noch mal daran denken dass
zwischen kroatien eu mitglied und
griechenland eu-mitglied noch ein paar
westbalkan staaten liegen die nicht eu
mitglied sind aber die eine natürliche
erwartung haben dass sie auch teilhaben
am europäischen eu im prozess was da
stattfindet ist das ein serbischer
präsident vujic durch die lande fährt
und in bosnien impfstoffe aus russland
und aus china abgibt und sich feiern ist
und zurückfährt und sagt schaudt ich
helfe euch aber die eu hilft euch nicht
und das ist eigentlich für mich das
große problem dass die eu hier in
ländern in denen jedoch eine große
erwartungshaltung ist ein großer respekt
gegenüber der eu 1 1 ein großes
versprechen
man fühlt durch die eu was dann
rechtsstaatlichkeit freiheit
organisation wirtschaftskraft und so
weiter präsentiert wird das sieht das in
diesem moment nicht umsetzt das ist ein
problem weil populistische politiker
springen da drauf und machen mit note
zulassung in ihrem eigenen land ein
eigenes süppchen und da finde ich sollte
brüssel sehr sehr sehr genau hinschauen
und sich fragen wie man jetzt hier
vorgehen kann ist es wahrscheinlich auch
eine frage an die deutsche
bundesregierung die dort einen großen
einfluss in der region warum geht man
jetzt nicht darauf zu und macht das ja
jetzt zum beispiel tschechien oder auch
mit österreich in einem pilotversuch
aber solidarität ist meiner ansicht nach
auch in diesen ländern die nicht allzu
oft geschaut wird in dieser situation
wichtig das problem haben die briten ja
nicht mehr sie müssen diese solidarität
ja nicht mehr üben kommt boris johnson
noch etwas anderes entgegen in
österreich in deutschland gibt es ja ein
ausgeprägtes föderalistisches system da
haben die länder chefinnen und chefs
eine menge mitzureden viele köche
könnten da unter umständen den brei
verderben in großbritannien durch das
wahlsystem kann er durch regieren ist
das eine große stärke im moment gerade
für die krone politik der briten ja ganz
sicher und natürlich auch um das nhl
das zentralisierte und das ist das ist
fern von perfekt aber es ist es hat sich
jetzt in der krise muss man sagen
wirklich sehr bewährt und und es gibt
sehr sehr viele freiwillige es ist eine
unglaubliche bewegung entstanden weil
irgend sie dürfen ja nicht vergessen
dass großbritannien viel mehr
menschenleben verloren hat als
deutschland nicht ich glaube fast
doppelt so viel obwohl die bevölkerung
geringer ist als eine verwandlung auf
die leichte schulter genommen hat
richtig und dann auch so eine hott
strategie dann normal also sie haben zu
spät alles gemacht und dann immer so hin
und her also es war wirklich fern von
ein gutes management die die ganze krise
aber in der impf bestattung des
impfstoffes und eben auch in der
verknüpfung das machen die unglaublich
zügig und selbst da hilft nur eine dose
die erste dose wird genau und sehr
kritisiert dass erst mal eine dusche
aber jetzt machen wir sind deutschland
auch so nicht habe das wurde gerade
jetzt also weil man ja da schon eine
gewisse immunität hat die ab 70 prozent
ja schon ganz gut dass mixa in
deutschland aus politischen und
strukturellen gründen vielleicht ein
bisschen schwieriger auch ist was noch
der zukunft ist eine irgendwie
verwirrende informationspolitik ich habe
in den letzten tagen war alles zu gemüte
geführt da sagen die einen werden zu
wenig impfstoff klar es wurde zunächst
mal zu wenig bestellt
andererseits haben wir ja auch zuviel
impfstoffe nämlich astrazeneca und
vergammeln jetzt angeblich millionenfach
in schränken seit heute werden auch die
menschen über 65 damit geimpft das gibt
jetzt auch eine zulassung hier
der regierende bürgermeister von berlin
sagte
alles halb so schlimm gestern zur
überraschung vieler zumindest in berlin
klappt das mit verteilung und
bereitstellung schon ziemlich gut was
ist denn da jetzt sache
das spielt natürlich auch wieder auch
über die medien gespielt aber es ist
irgendwie verwirrend
also es ist auf jeden fall eine
aufgeregte debatte wo es sehr viele
persönliche erfahrungen reinspielen man
sagt auch ich habe noch keinen
impftermin und es klappt hier überhaupt
nichts und so weiter also das ist der
eine emotionale teil der zweite teil der
sache teil da wird es auch ein bisschen
vermischt damit also ist aber einfach
fakt der impfstoff für 450 millionen
menschen muss einfach produziert werden
ja und pfizer und
bei und text in den usa einfach so stark
und können dass so viel auch für impfen
weil sie da über pfizer
produktionsanlagen haben wo es
hergestellt wird und das haben wir ja
auch schon angesprochen was gut gerade
gesagt das problem ist ja nicht die
entwicklung sondern die industriellen
aktion es ist die industrielle
produktion und das hat ja auch der
bayern tag konnte hier in deutschland
gesagt es wird ja dieses werk es ist ja
ein werk in irgendwo in hessen jetzt
glaube ich eine eröffnet marburg in
marburg genau eröffnet worden und da
wird jetzt auch produziert und ich
glaube eben wir werden wirklich in vier
monaten hier sitzen und da werden die
impfdosen in der apotheke wahrscheinlich
vorhanden sein also ich glaube man kommt
einfach nicht nach mit der produktion
das ist das eine und bei astrazeneca das
sind auch sehr widersprüchliche signale
zu hören es gibt halt bundesländer
die haben schon die zweite impfdosen
zurückgelegt und die steht dann im
kühlschrank und wird eben nicht verimpft
zum beispiel dann gibt es bundesländer
da kommen leute nicht zur impfung und
die sind zu unflexibel dann die nächsten
einzuladen weil eben auch so strenge
vorgaben sind meine frage ging nach
einer um eine chaotische
informationspolitik bei den schnelltest
das ja nicht sehr viel besser da sagen
die ein wir hätten zu wenig die anderen
zum beispiel der
bundesgesundheitsminister ist der
meinung seien ja genügend schon im lande
trotzdem wird jetzt erst ab anfang april
flächendeckend getestet bei den
selbsttests ist noch schöner
da heißt es die vielen angeblich alle
weil die nämlich in china hergestellt
werden dass gerade hier neues feste
arbeitet niemand jetzt hört man dass
discounter schon am wochenende die
verkaufen wollen und die drogeriemärkte
nächste woche also das heißt diese
widersprüchlichen informationen die
jeden tag hundert und tausendfach darin
den in die öffentlichkeit gepumpt werden
tragen ja auch noch zu dieser verwirrung
sei die ja auch gestern durch die
ergebnisse des des gipfels entstanden
sind
also wir haben es aber auch seit einem
jahr mit einem system zu tun das
learning by doing ist ja also es hat vor
einem jahr ja niemand gewusst dass diese
pandemie so groß wird es hat niemand
geahnt dass binnen sieben monaten
impfstoff da war es hat auch niemand
ahnt dass diese tests in diversen formen
so schnell da sein könnten
aber natürlich ist es richtig man hätte
das zeit
der sommerpause seit oktober besser
organisieren können und diese test
strategie wie es geht zeigt zum beispiel
frankreich in frankreich steht oder in
paris an jeder zweiten straßenecke ein
kleines zelt und da kann jeder bürger
reingehen kann sich kostenlos testen
lassen und hat nach einer viertelstunde
das ergebnis und das gibt es in
deutschland nicht besser organisiert als
bei uns ja und ich glaube es ist einfach
das in deutschland vielleicht ist es
auch ein bisschen das deutsche dass man
alles so super exakt organisieren muss
zum abhaken 0 durch ja aber
entschuldigung es geht ja es geht ja ich
bin so ein bisschen irritiert dass ich
aus der deutschen politik höre dass man
jetzt in diesem monat anfängt eine test
strategie zu entwickeln und sich fragt
wo ob genügend es da sind also die
anämie ist ein jahr alt wir wissen von
anfang an dass das testen wichtig ist
bei der impfstoffproduktion und
herstellung und entwicklung gebe ich ihn
komplett recht da sind wir alle
gedanklich schneller als wahrscheinlich
sein können aber beim testen ist es so
hier in österreich
das muss man sich mal vor augen führen
wird seit ich glaube viert im dezember
in großen hallen umsonst mit
medizinischem personal schnell getestet
das ist standard da kann jeder hin jeder
kann zu jedem zeitpunkt ich brauche noch
nicht mal eine österreichische
sozialversicherung skate ich gehe dahin
mit meinem perso und bin in 20 minuten
durch raus getestet und kann dann
zu hause oder bei der arbeit oder jetzt
beim friseur sagen hier
ich bin zumindest heute negativ getestet
worden
und das interessante ist dass zu beginn
dieser ganzen geschichte die die
akzeptanz bei der bevölkerung nicht
besonders groß weil die es war ein
riesen eine riesen organisation
betrieben worden es hat perfekt
funktioniert und die leute haben es
nicht richtig angenommen und dass das
der entscheidende moment war dann jetzt
als man gesagt hat man macht das so
genannte eintritts test man möchte ist
natürlich nicht das frei testen nennen
obwohl es das im grunde ist wir
versuchen es über den friseur nach
dieser shut down phase wenn ihr zum
friseur wollt dann müsst ihr euch testen
lassen frei testen lassen
ab dem zeitpunkt war das gegrummel ich
in österreich zumindest vorbei sondern
testen dann ist man zum friseur gegangen
und der nächste schritt wird sein
bei der gastro öffnung und in meiner
sicht wenn das wirklich kommt zu ostern
wird das natürlich auch mit einem
negativen test gemacht und der nächste
schritt ist dann der urlaub der so
genannte grüne passt da sind wir dann
bei der kurzreise heute nochmal nach
nach israel aber ich verstehe nicht
warum es hier in österreich funktioniert
und warum es in deutschland wo die
situation überhaupt nicht anders ist
nicht funktioniert sagt ein extrablatt
eine stadthalle aufzumachen und da die
tische hinzustellen und unter den
arbeiter samariter bund mit ins boot zu
holen und es gibt tausende gut geschulte
medizinstudent mediziner sonst irgendwie
diesem test vernünftig machen können man
macht ihn ja auch nicht selbst an er
wird fachgerecht gemacht hat ein
top-ergebnis und trägt hierzulande
zumindest zu einer doch respekt daten
corona strategie mit bei und nimmt auch
momentan bisschen den druck aus der
debatte
man wird der große unterschied zu
deutschland ist jetzt einfach der dass
in deutschland auch getestet werden
konnte aber dann musste eben 49 oder 99
euro dafür hingelegt werden und es
konnten sich eben bei weitem nicht alle
leisten und es ist auch viel zu spät
auch der politik hier eingefallen dass
möglicherweise menschen die 500 euro im
monat einkommen haben oder jetzt ein
kurzarbeitergeld dass die sich niemals
testen lassen können weil es einfach zu
teuer ist und hier an diesen punkten ist
sagen ja genau das ist ein massives
versagen weil in deutschland die ärzte
und apotheker daran verdient haben an
die
tests wären in den ländern ringsherum
diese tests kostenlos durchgeführt
wurden sollen ja 25 euro 5 stück kosten
also auch nicht für jedermann machbar
thomas kutschker und ich habe es ja
gerade angesprochen die reise nach
jerusalem heute von sebastian kurz und
der dänischen ministerpräsidenten zu
tricksen bei der eu kommission in der eu
hat man gehört das doch ganz gut man
wenn man sich noch woanders irgendwie
umsieht und sich woanders entdeckt ist
es wirklich so dass man in brüssel das
sozusagen als souveräne entscheidung von
zwei ländern österreich und dänemark mit
israel zu kooperieren hingenommen hat
und sich dabei nichts weiter denkt und
das vielleicht sogar noch gut findet
oder sind wirklichkeit die verärgerung
groß dass das jetzt passiert ist ja also
da muss man ganz klar sagen die
kommission hat gute miene zum bösen
spiel gemacht
sie ist natürlich in einer geschwächten
lage
wir haben ja schon gehört von den
kollegen die ganze kritik die es gibt
von der natürlich auch viele
regierungschefs die probleme gerne nach
brüssel weiter schieben dass es immer so
und das ist jetzt in dieser krise
natürlich besonders so aber die
kommission kann sich auch nicht ohne
weiteres davon stehlen nein man ist
natürlich nicht glücklich über diese
alleingänge man muss ja noch mal wenn
man sich zurück denkt in den vergangenen
sommer ist wäre sehr einfach gewesen für
deutschland frankreich italien und die
niederlande das waren die vier länder
die ja am anfang die initiative
ergriffen haben selbst impfstoff zu
bestellen auf eigene faust das sind ja
die vier länder kommt noch regen dazu in
denen auch die impfstoffhersteller
sitzen
die haben also den direkten draht die
haben die finanzkraft die hätten sich
eindecken können aber was wir mit den
ganzen anderen ländern geworden was wäre
denn mit slowenien geworden und nicht
zuletzt auch mit österreich und dänemark
das sind ja zwei kleine länder die keine
produktion bei sich haben
die wären natürlich leer ausgegangen
deswegen war das eine sehr
eminent wichtige entscheidung zu sagen
man beschafft den impfstoff gemeinsam
und verteilt ihn dann proportional nach
anzahl der bevölkerung auf die länder um
eben zu verhindern dass wir hier ein
wettrennen haben wo die großen zu
impfstoff kommen die kleinen ausgehen
oder was die andere variante gewesen
wäre deutschland und frankreich dann
quasi großzügig entscheiden müssen wer
denn in der eu wie viel impfstoff von
ihnen ab bekommt so und wenn jetzt
länder gerade die kleinen länder sich
aus dieser solidarität verabschieden
würde ich sagen spielen sie selbst mit
dem feuer denn sie provozieren
die großen staaten und das merkt man
heute auch schon an den reaktionen aus
paris zu sagen gut wenn ihr das nicht
mehr weit dann machen wir es in der
zweiten und dritten generation auf
eigene faust und wenn man jetzt mal
genau hinsieht was ist das heute gewesen
für eine ins rallye anz ich weiß nicht
vielleicht kann der kollege in wien das
ja erklären ich habe es nicht verstanden
da haben sich also drei länder die keine
impfstoffe produzieren getroffen und
eine in fabians gegründet die also nur
in dieser gründung besteht mit nicht
unterlegtes es heißt irgendwie 50
millionen möchte man für forschung
aufwenden lassen aber nichts
unterschrieben worden
und wer weiß um welche summen es hier
geht da muss man natürlich sagen da sind
50 millionen euro wirklich herkunft
leider kann ich ihnen helfen dieses
diese wissenslücke möglicherweise leicht
zu überbrücken auch für den zuschauer
denn sebastian kurz hat heute am
flughafen in tel aviv erklärt was
eigentlich vorhatte ich hoffe doch dass
wir heute eine konkrete vereinbarung im
bereich der zusammenarbeit der forschung
aber auch im bereich der zusammenarbeit
der koproduktion abschließen können
darauf haben wir uns vorbereitet ja
wolfgang ullrich vorbereitet es ist eine
stiftung glaube ich gegründet worden
aber sehr viel mehr ist nicht passiert
oder ja ganz genau die hatte einem
gründungskapital oder soll einst haben
von 50 millionen euro und herkunft
völlig recht das ist natürlich
wahnsinnig wenig es wurde dann blumig
beschrieben dass also andere länder auch
noch interesse hätten oder irgendwann
dazu kommen sollten oder wollten
außerdem möchte man die entwicklung von
impfstoffen die auch für varianten dann
zur verfügung stehen in der zukunft
voranbringen
[Musik]
was soll man dazu sagen nicht das herz
oder falls ja in den mund nehmen
vielleicht muss man ein bisschen schauen
wo es herkommt es war ja am anfang
dieser pandemie im vergangenen frühjahr
so dass es diese gruppe der first mover
es gab so nannten die sich der heute
also österreich dazu singapur australien
eben auch isa ich glaube auch dänemark
und noch ein paar andere die sich
verabredet haben und immer mal geschaut
haben was tun wir es also ein
gedankenaustausch stehen wir was machen
wir gerade wie kommen wir mit unseren
maßnahmen gegen diese erste welle an
möglicherweise sollte das jetzt also
noch mal ein versuch sein dass
aufzuwerten jetzt hören wir dass also
der tschechische ministerpräsident bagis
in ein paar tagen auch nach israel
fahren möchte helmut kalt völlig recht
es gibt in der eu in der wissenschaft
instrumente mit wahnsinnig viel geld
wahnsinnig viel forschung nach vorne zu
bringen und es scheint auch mir ein ein
guter und zielführender weg zu sein
und natürlich gab es die kritik sofort
ja nicht nur aus frankreich sondern auch
wenn ich das richtig weiß aus italien
aus rom
das war ein aus meiner sicht ein
bisschen seltsamer move vor allen dingen
weil man ja wenn man auf kurz gucken
sagen muss das ja eigentlich von beginn
dieser ganzen panini an zu denen gehört
die sehr klar kommuniziert haben sehr
klar bis auf ausnahmen ich da gerne auch
noch mal in ischgl und ein paar andere
momente aber doch sehr klar auch eine
sache das wollen wir machen so ziehen
wir das durch das sind die züge die wir
in d
in die hand nehmen jetzt dieser auftritt
heute und auch von ein paar tagen diese
seltsame ankündigung von lockerungen
wenn denn die inzidenz mitspielen wenn
der frühling kommt und warm wird und wir
uns draußen aufhalten wenn denn die
impfdosen so kommen wie sie sollen wenn
denn alle sich testen lassen
ich habe das gefühl da geht es gerade
druck er hat das gefühl er muss etwas
tun er hat das gefühl er muss sich nach
vorne stellen
europäisch war das sicher nicht vom
credo erinnert dass ein bisschen das
verhalten von sebastian kurz auch an das
verhalten von boris johnson der doch
sehr stark auch versucht aktionistisch
zu sein auch die politische show ganz
gut beherrscht auch auf in politische
ereignisse reagiert ist das irgendwie
vergleichbar dass man dass da zwei
versuche sich als macher zu verkaufen
frage mit welchem erfolg ja also brauche
ich dann würde ich sagen beherrscht die
politische show besonders gut das ist
eine seiner ganz großen stärken erinnern
sich nur wie er den rexit vertrag als er
dann also denn irgendwie weihnachtszeit
endlich zustande kam dieses diesem
großen packen und das hat er dann
gezeigt um fernsehen und gesagt als ich
hier ist es hat er dann so rausgeholt
wie sie kleinen dreiminütigen
fernsehansprache dass der aktionismus
das macht er sehr gut und er ist aber
auch er ist wirklich besser geworden in
der krise das muss man schon sagen es
ist einerseits hat man das gefühl das
passiert was und die briten impfen sehr
schnell aber andererseits ist ja auch
ruhiger geworden in seiner kommunikation
und etwas bedachter also er ist er hat
das super am anfang ja sehr auf die
leichte schulter genommen das tut er
nicht mehr sieht sicherlich auch daran
dass er ja sehr krank war ich glaube
sogar noch kränker als man es generell
wusste und daher weiß wie schlimm diese
krankheit ist und dieser eröffnungsband
es ja sehr konkret von der britischen
regierung der ist aber schon immer
gekoppelt an incidents zahlen und wie
sich das aber hat ja eigentlich
angekündigt dass ab juni
alles wieder ganz normal als 21 juni und
die briten suchen also auch schon ihre
sommerreisen wie verrückt und werden die
ganzen sundance die ganzen sätzen zum
leid der deutschen und das ja das ist
das in deutschland immer jahren aus an
spanischen stränden liegen mit tischen
hand sie können vielleicht eine frage in
dem zusammenhang ist es schon kurz
angesprochen worden
dieser digitale eu umfasst er uns jetzt
das reisen wieder erleichtern soll oder
möglicherweise den eintritt in
kulturelle veranstaltungen
freizeitveranstaltungen fußballspiele
und so weiter wenn jetzt einige eu
länder wie ungarn oder slowakei jetzt
nicht zertifizierte impfstoffe benutzten
nämlich sinopharm aus china und sputnik
aus russland dann ist ein solcher
digitaler infos er völlig wertlos denn
auf dieser app können ja diese beiden
impfstoffe gar nicht auftauchen na ja
ich werde nicht sagen dass er völlig
wertlos ist aber dann ist eben der
träger dieses impfpass es nicht zugangs
berechtigt für veranstaltungen innerhalb
der europäischen union die zertifiziert
ist prädikat vernunft bekommen haben
außerdem ist es ja jetzt auch so dass er
heute glaube ich die ära den
zulassungsprozess für sputnik 5
zumindest begonnen hat das kann sein
dass es bis juni zum beispiel
abgeschlossen wird und dann eben auch
der russische impfstoff gilt aber im
prinzip ist dann derjenige der ein
impfpass hat er nicht diesen gültigen
regeln entspricht der wird dann eben
leider draußen bleiben müssen das ist er
dann glaube ich das problem des trägers
stuttgart das was cerstin gammelin da
gerade angesprochen hat das ist der
zusagen die vorprüfung dieses
impfstoffes in brüssel das sogenannte
roaming review also sputnik der
russische impfstoff ist in dieser
vorprüfung und wenn die einigermaßen
zufriedenstellend abläuft dann gibt es
tatsächlich auch ein zulassungsverfahren
das auch eine zeit lang dauern wird der
ema der europäischen arzneimittelagentur
was
ist das eine sinnvolle strategie die
auch unterstützt dass man jetzt auch
russischen impfstoff und möglicherweise
auch chinesischen impfstoff überprüft
einerseits um die mengen defizite
auszugleichen und andererseits wieder
auch die osteuropäischen länder näher an
brüssel zu binden
die kommission hat heute sehr klar
gesagt dass sie das für zwei
unterschiedliche prozesse hält das eine
ist die zulassung des impfstoffs und das
bedeutet erstmal nichts anderes als dass
das haftungsrisiko in diesem thema
zulassungsverfahren auf den hersteller
übergeht wenn die staaten das als
notfall zulassung auf den markt bringen
so wie es jetzt ungarn zum beispiel
getan hat dann übernehmen sie auch das
gesamte haftungsrisiko davon werden sie
dann befreit am ende dieses prozesses
aber der andere prozess die bestellung
von hemmstoffen da hat die kommission
gesagt darüber haben wir überhaupt keine
entscheidung getroffen ob wir dann also
auch als eu einen rahmenvertrag hierfür
sputnik abschließen werden
eine starke vermutung ist dass wir im
juni dieses problem nicht mehr haben
weil dann nun tatsächlich so viele
impfstoff bekommen dass ihr das
umgekehrte problem sein wird können die
staaten das eigentlich schnell genug für
impfen
und natürlich muss man auch sagen dass
die eu bedingungen gestellt hat an
impfstoffe wo sie rahmenverträge
abschließend eine bedingung war dass der
impfstoff in europa produziert werden
soll und das ist bei sputnik ja bisher
nicht der fall
es gibt ja bei den impfstoffen jetzt in
vielen ländern die hat man ja
entschieden diese impfstoffe kostenlos
abzugeben das sind enorme mengen die zum
teil ja auch sehr teuer sind
die frage der finanzierung und des
schuldenmachens in dem zusammenhang mit
vielen anderen schulden machen den
ökonomischen und sozialen fragen in
europa fliegt uns das noch mal um die
ohren also es schwer zu sagen man muss
einfach jetzt so an die sache glaube ich
angehen dass man nicht beim impfen
sparen kann auch nicht beim testen
sparen sollte gleichwohl ist es in
deutschland auf jeden fall so dass
die wirtschaftshilfe man auch die
gesundheits- und so alten mustern folgen
und da hätte man wesentlich kreativer
sein können auf jeden fall also auch bei
diesen hilfen für unternehmen und nicht
immer nur auf die verlierer schauen auch
diejenigen die gewinn bei der krise zum
beispiels amazon vielleicht
vorübergehend direkt auch doch schon mal
eine digital steuer einzuführen um im
prinzip ein bisschen ausgleich zu
schaffen wirtschaftlich dass die
schulden eben nicht so weit anwachsen
aber ich glaube auch angesichts der
zinspolitik und angesichts der
pandemischen lage ist jetzt die wahl
nicht sehr groß die auswahl nicht sehr
groß ich glaube da muss einfach jetzt
erst mal geklappt werden wer geimpft ist
das vereinigte königreich kann nicht auf
dauer von brt exit und impfen leben was
kommt dann
über den tag hinaus betrachtet naja ich
glaube haupt sich wenn diese wars
johnson fliegt jetzt im moment aus
dieser erfolg wolke von von von den
impfungen aber das praxis und die folgen
des city werden jan richtig im zwar in
einem zweiten halbjahr und nächstes jahr
wird man die wirklich führen und und das
wird wehtun der britischen wirtschaft
mehr als der europäischen union
und da wird glaube ich noch das böse
erwachen kommen also erhöhen
gerade die steuererhöhungen angekündigt
gericht ich also diese dieser honeymoon
der im moment er ist der wird nicht
andauern
ulrich mit der bitte um eine kurze
antwort hat noch etwas mehr als eine
minute
diese zentrifugalkräfte die sich in
mittelosteuropa in südosteuropa zeigen
werden die wenn das mit dem impfen
geklärt ist wenn europa durch geimpft
ist möglicherweise sich wiedergeben oder
sehen sie da weitere probleme die sich
am info nur besonders exemplarisch
zeigen also die werden sich nicht legen
die werden mit der zeit größer werden
eine nachricht möchte ich gerne noch
loswerden wenn sie mal schauen bei allem
ärger den wir haben meine beobachtung
ist dass populistische regierungen diese
krise nicht besser im griff haben
schauen sich die katastrophale lage in
den krankenhäusern in ungarn tschechien
slowakei an
schauen sie zu wenigen an wo 67 tage
lang gar kein gesundheitsminister war
sondern premierminister jantscher meinte
da selber zu machen zu können
und in genau dieser zeit ungefähr 1500
mensch
ein qubit gestorben sind das sollte für
uns auch noch eine lehre sein noch mal
drauf zu gucken welchen wert auch
rechtsstaatlich geführte gut
organisierte demokratien in dieser
situation haben
aber eins ist klar diese sache wird uns
noch beschäftigen und die
zentrifugalkräfte werden mit dieser
geschichte meiner ansicht nach größer
als kleiner gut wie werden die blessuren
der eu kommission oder wieviel blessuren
wird die eu-kommission abkriegen dadurch
dieses nicht besonders professionell
gemanagte diese professionell gemanagte
impfkampagne bleibt da was hängen wird
dass die arbeit der kommission in
zukunft weiter erschweren
abgerechnet wird am schluss wenn die eu
kommission dieses selbst gesteckte ziel
erreicht und das müssen sie ja dann die
staaten vor allem erreichen wenn die
weise umsetzen
die herdenimmunität bis zum ende des
sommers zu erreichen
dann glaube ich wird sie ganz gut aus
dieser sache rauskommen und wenn nicht
dann muss man sagen hat sie eben auch
einen kampf verloren um mehr kompetenzen
in der gesundheitspolitik war es
jedenfalls bei grenzüberschreitenden
pandemien sicher sinnvoll wäre
da kann man nicht alles national machen
aber natürlich musik zeigen dass sie es
kann
und das wird jetzt in den nächsten
monaten sich entscheiden und eine eu
kommission die kompetenzen verliert
verliert sie dann wahrscheinlich nicht
nur in der gesundheitspolitik und das
wird auch weitere kontroversen in europa
geben ich bedanke mich bei calw in
gammelin bei wende linie von bredow bei
wolf christian unrichtig und bei thomas
kutschker liebe zuschauer ich empfehle
ihnen eine gesprächssendung eine
diskussionssendung am kommenden sonntag
bei phoenix um 13 uhr forum demokratie
mit dem thema demokratie in privaten wie
politisch ist die welt der social media
moderiert von michaela kolster jetzt
folgt phoenix der tag mit sarah wildau
themen unter anderem das trendbarometer
der deutschland wenn sie haben vorhin
grafik schon gezeigt mit allen
umfrageergebnissen zur aktuellen
corona situation natürlich bleiben sie
bei uns
[Musik]